哈喽各位同学大家晚安
刚刚在上面有看到同学
这个这位同学每个礼拜都来聊追女生的事情
那你是问我要怎么样细水长流
我在学生时期就把我老婆定下来
所以我觉得你不要问我啦
我们是定下来以后细水长流到现在
并不是前面的细水长流
这样
好不好
所以我也不知道
来
那
那我看一下
我同学问2327明天是不是好的观察点
我在讲2327国具的同学
很好
你的观察很棒
是说
今天的尾盘
我们来看小10K
今天尾盘这一段
今天尾盘
全台湾各大股票几乎都是尾盘在拉
那我蛮喜欢它拉在这个月的靠近月底的附近
像今天25号嘛对不对
所以如果它能够在这个月底这边走出一些行情
其实对于下个月的月底月初的这一段
其实是对多头是有利的
然后熟悉的2474来握叫出来
你说可乘对不对
破底翻左侧与右侧块对称
你讲的应该是假突破吧
就是你讲的是上面
上面的这个吧
其实上面这个
我的确看到上面很多压力
但是有没有完全对称的
这个我不敢说
因为我看到的是这边高
高低
所以是这样子斜斜的这样子下来的概念
对啊
我只知道说
如果我有多单
我不想吃在这个地方
这样子
因为这边
你说要涨上去吗
有啦
目前看起来两天三天在这边
但是上面这压力重重
我能够打得破这个多单的这个城墙吗
我不知道
所以这样子
周K吃在316
周K
这周K好漂亮哦
好漂亮這疫苗打出來就是前一週好美這一週這些整个框框区域打击区拍拍手这位同学赞哦很好很好
这个整体而言我觉得这很棒
那预计365出一些这附近
你心里要有底
过了350以后
360、365这附近
这一整块
什么时候会遇到压力我不知道
遇到压力以后会不会继续走
我不知道
但是我眼前看到是前波套牢的人
从这边就开始
这边包含这个边界大概350
350以上就开始有套牢
所以你心里就有个底这样子
那如果你有预计在这边出一些
假设到360跟365差5块钱而已
是我我就随意出一出才差5块
然后反正我后面还有
你说还有牡丹
一路跟他赌喷出
很好
包含这个喷出的距离
1比1
我觉得来到这附近
很好的规划
我觉得同学都很棒啊
真的
有人问我说结婚了吗
今年还没
今年还没结婚
最近其实蛮多股票是在好的位置
然后我看一下
还有同学问002606
这应该是中国的股票
我看一下002606
这个吗
你要问什么
日线是不是可以打击
同样的这个破底翻
在这边我会有点
有点犹豫的感觉
这个同样的破底翻
因为它这边掉进这个区间内
这边这边这边
然后底下有撑没错
所以如果我真的要吃
如果真的要吃可以我就手短短的所谓短短的就是这样子而已
就这样子我没有打算手到最下面这里去
不用不用
我就手这个
这样子
那你要就要在这边其实甚至出现
出现这样子的隔壁这一两天这附近
他就要有有能力这样子
有能力稍微这样长出去这才代表做多的人其实是有
有意图的
那后面的单子才比较有机会继续走来后面还有什么呢今天在小纳上来我的小纳我今天哭哭
我在这边做交易
我讲解一下我的小纳好了
我在这边摸一个边界二
这个这里亏
这样子
然后这个亏其实亏不多
好像亏多少
400还是多少钱
我忘记了
那这个点 我的这个点我并不是在5k吃的
我是我也不是在1k吃哦
我是看到他长上来了
哇 亲眼看着他上来 哭哭我没有部位
然后我就挂了 我就用预挂
我想说抓这个参考点我就预挂单挂在这边
结果我同一时间我跑去挂我的IB
IB那边的单子我也有挂 做同样的事情
只是这边我挂在这里我没有吃到
因为我没有去精算到底是哪一个价格
然后我回来看到IBX大概两个TIC
吃到这个部位
然后等我回来看的时候已经在这边
我就啊
然后果然就是这一错过就到天上去了
还好啦
这样子
对我是直接出金的账号
对我是直接买我就懒得考试
然后现在结果现在在这边
现在这边不好做了
这里不好做
所以来注意看
我吃这个单子是因为
我看到这个地方
然后我想说
好算了就挂在这边
然后同一时间我就切过去挂那个
然后挂完了
我其实是离开店了
想说好了
回来再说这样子
怎么吃的
很简单啊
就是挂单
来我看到这样子的时候
我看到这样子
我心里面有抓一个破底翻约略会出现的位置
如果有机会回来
这边对这边
哦好
那不如我就挂这边
然后防守防一个外面的这样子的地方
我就做这件事情
我这样目测防守大概20点吧
这样
对啊我就这样挂着
然后就
就这样给他
所以
居然刚好点到
也有可能没吃到啊
我的IB那边就没吃到啊
哭哭
然后所以我今天所有的这些交易全部长这样子然后我后来还要跑去玩了一下黄金哎呦 玩输了就赶快回来这样
黄金在这边
黄金在这里
在这里
这里
我只有出手这个
这个是拿钱没有获利
然后看到黄金在这个地方
好啦
我手非常的短哦
好
输了就算了
我后面就不管了这样
那个很硬啊
很难吃到
因为那个瞬间这样 咔一分k这样而已
那你说来
如果你错过小那的1k
说真的
如果中午这时候你有看盘
这里你应该不容易错过
错过这个边界
你应该不容易
尤其是
在11点的这个
这个地方
这个
来我记得我有讲过我们的早盘
很习惯在11点或11点半这附近
然后如果前面有一个下沙 沙到一个地方大概会是一个停顿点
有人记得吗
这个时间点跟台湾的大户们都去休息 包含
加上中国的股票他们11点半是休息的
这些都有因素
所以那个点
这里很好吃
这个附近
如果你错过这个点
这里很好吃
这时候我在干嘛
我在准备出门吃饭
所以就这样
黄金5K抓多少停损我不知道
我就随便按啊来我当时吃的就是这样子啊
我吃五口微型的而已
我这边预设是五我就直接这样子五口微型的
然后就给他停损放在这个地方
所以看一下这看一下记录记录是
看一下亏多少
来 最后这边黄金五口亏170这里这里
买进去两分钟五秒就死掉了
所以没有了
有人说2308是我会I用的地方吗
好了 我放在投影片里面
你怎么那么了解我
这里直接先讲好了
我今天加了台达电
对
我现在有四张的台打电
我今天又加
我当初的想法其实就是这样子
就是
好懂我
可恶我做什么事情都被大家看懂了
这样好恐怖喔
来我当初我记得我有一封那个YouTube上面
不是FB上面的发文
有没有
我不是发一个来我找一下
我在旁边的萤幕找一下
我不是有发这篇吗
我不是说日线的台达电
然后我不是说这日线好明显
对不对
我的脑袋里就是破底翻
好 那我们来到真实的行情在这边
这个破底翻的概念在我脑袋里面这里
这个边界
是我
很在乎的边界这个
所以我在这边其实有部位老虞你有没有摊平有我摊平了
但是我的摊平是在一个
一个
我认知的
破底翻的这里我用区间的角度
区间的角度
反正我就是吃在這個附近這樣子
那今天之後其實我還有餘兒可以繼續吃
我還有這個想法
這樣
所以有人說老魚不是要尖尖的隔壁吃嗎
這是個好問題
這幾這兩天其實他也的確出現這樣
我想說好假設我總共有7張10張可以吃
那我預計我要吃多少張我就先想好嗎
我前面不要吃太多 我就先吃一两张 试试看
好 然后这边我又再吃了一张
这里吃一张 所以我的均价约略落在这附近
均价就是在这
那这个均价跟我在做破底翻的概念其实很像
我就要在这
那我后面也可能大概还有一倍的金额左右可以去吃这只股票
所以我用有点区间的概念去捕捉
我先小单,小单子试单
试试,错了我回来
如果对了,好啊,开始加
大概是这个概念
IBMQ要开始建仓吗?要9月的
对,我其实要准备要开始建到9月去了
只是今天早上
早上没有吃到
超不爽
11点那个很难抓啦
对啊
所以剩下来的就是
就是我现在就只能等啊
等他看有什么日线格局的回答再说了好不好好好 然後我要講什麼啊來 同學的問題 上面我看一下
ARM COHR
AARM COHR
我看一下
ARM不錯
是不錯,邊界來一樣這個邊界開始有人用
那其實你在他是跳空對不對
所以你可以開始抓一下
這附近其實都是一個值得觀察的這個邊界
他的打擊區
Cohr
这也是
这个的概念又来了
这边的最低价在这个地方
所以边界其实就是抓这里
对过来这附近这些地方
这个边界有点宽
大概27几 28几
这些地方都是
不要到太高啦
285就有点高
所以抓一个边界
大概以280为中间
我上下5块钱
大概是这样子的边界
我觉得是很不错的
这样
6742也是美美的
我看一下
你们看到我看到股票
我的第一个动作
像刚刚的图是长这样子
我都会第一个动作先习惯
往后退一步
看一下大格局的样子
好在大格局偏下圆
然后瞄一下周K的样子
OK周K偏下缘
周K也有这个尖尖的
好所以这附近是打击区的附近
只是他的周K在这个地方也有蛮多套牢的人
包含这个边界
甚至前面有这么大一个套牢区域
然后加上全部都在套牢在上面
好那我心里有个底了
如果他之后要长
他不容易瞬间蹦蹦蹦蹦就这样长上去
你看一下
前一次上面这么多套牢的人 他在底下整理了从11月整理到5月
有没有 所以这一次的确有东西 但是因为这边搭配上这堆好多人套在上面所以我可以慢慢的建仓我不用急
所以问这个美美的的同学说
这个美美的
你可以不用急
你不会慢慢堆慢慢堆
然后在这个边界
他可能还是会一段时间
在这里上下的震荡这样子
心里要有个底
好不好
2014中红
中宏日线16.75的价位是很大的平台吗
16.75
就这里吗
是啊
但是你说
大的平台就一定不会破或是怎么样
我不知道
但是我只知道是
最近这段时间很多人用
那你要记得一件事情
来这里有个东西要讲
这么多人用的东西
而且也有微微的出现破底翻的概念
那最近这两天麻烦了
因为只要它是用这种角度
只要它是用这种这样子的角度
它再度回来到这个地方
往这边走的几率就会高很多
所以你不要再想说
哇这个边界很多人用
因为反过来讲这个边界也很多人用
好那现在你可以不理它没错
现在这个位置有点夹在中间
我不知道要干嘛
但是如果他来的时候是带着一大堆
下沙的黑黑的这种力量
然后或是上影线的力量下来的时候
先不要当第一个
慢慢的等
好不好
我的公学椅
我觉得还不错啊
我这什么牌的
这台湾的
我想想看
我已经忘记了
亚说
亚说的牌子
這樣
結果我講半天
可惡讓我講半天
好那你要問我6472是什麼
等一下我先
這個我先截起來我還不知道你講什麼
欸欸欸欸欸欸欸欸欸欸 你剛剛問的東西在哪裡啊 我找不到了欸好多留言 我找不到了那我就直接用我的這個講底下很漂亮啊
現在就抱著而已
現在沒有事情做
如果你在底下這邊有吃到的
那就這樣吧
你就抱著讓它繼續往上噴
然後這邊會震盪是很合理的事情
因為這邊一個小滿足
所以就等他震盪完看 會不會繼續把它噴上去
2492華星科今天吃尾盤
今天吃尾盤算聰明喔 你說尾盤我大概看一下
你吃尾盤的概念 我在猜你應該是想要賭這個日線的下影線對不對
你要賭這件事情
那我就這樣看
可以
因為這個邊界跟這個邊界是有
有
他們有在防守
你看
市場上有一群人
我不知道是誰
早盤都放給他
然後尾盤才把他吃回來
可以啊
那注意哦
如果你單純從小時可以看尾盤吃是撞強單沒錯
但是如果你是用在日線吃的角度
你只是在尾盤吃的
你要堵这个尖尖的隔壁在这边鬼混
然后有效的话
这个我会给过
什么时候直播吹萨克什风
我们是不是改天把直播的时间往前拉个半个小时
好不好
不然我现在吹九点钟
我吹下去
你知道萨克什风多大声吗
我吹下去楼上楼下的所有的邻居全部要跑来抗议了
好不好
如果要我吹我会提早公告
就是吹给大家听
但是我先讲
我现在学2月买萨克斯
三月开始学
然后我现在最近这个暑假
已经两个月完全没有找老师
因为我跟他讲我暑假超忙
还会出国玩还会干嘛的
所以我就直接先暂停
所以要的话就下礼拜或下下礼拜
看情形这样好不好
早上NQ吃7點15K
NQ如果是早上那個點我覺得應該不錯啊
我看一下15K
7點鐘
7點鐘是不是這個
跟我吃的
我看他是不是7點
7點 等一下
7點
吃在這裡
這就是我講的有點尷尬的單子
這裡 如果你是吃在
吃在這根
的15K 坦白講有點尷尬
我知道你在幹嘛
但是他尷尬的點就是
這個大K棒
搭配這種地方
這就是我沒有那麼
愛的點
那個時候我沒有看盤 我沒有下單 我也沒話說
這樣啊
OK
現在各位我看到不一樣的東西囉
眼前的K棒
這個應該有支撐的地方
反過來在這裡沒有支撐
所以往這邊走的機率怎麼樣
高很多
所以如果要做多的這個地方不要亂摸
上面斜斜的 底下平平的
不要亂摸 做多的人
好不好
好啦 那我就先来聊今天的主题
其实今天的主题是好玩的角度
因为其实刚好我刚刚自己做的单子
也正好拿来聊今天的主题
这样
OK
来 今天的主题是这个
为什么亏损也是赚钱
明明是亏的 但是却是赚的
我这边会聊期望值的概念
那这个期望值其实我没有打算聊得很细
大家不是数学系
所以不需要去算数学
但是你要知道的是
我们上个礼拜是不是在讲
盈亏是同源的
对吧
你要舍得去承受那个亏损
你才有机会去赚那个利润
这是最近一直在讲的东西
那我会带出21点是因为
在21点的这个角度里面
等一下
21点我先跳出来后面讲
这里
在21点的角度里面
它有一个东西叫做Basic Strategy
这个基本策略
它直接告诉我们说
当你的庄家
你是去赌的嘛
当庄家
它牌面上翻出来的卡
是2345678910或是S
牌面上翻出来的卡是这些的话
你要怎么做
H代表Hit就是发牌
我还要再发一张
然後這是你自己的卡
兩張牌加起來總共是5-7還是8還是9假設我是12對方翻出來的牌面是3那我就對過來
所以我要幹嘛
我要發牌 我還要再拿一張叫Hit
然後這裡某些時候他就這個叫做Stand
Stand就是指我不要了
我不要 我Pass 我不發牌了
然後像這個D
D是指Double
Double的意思是指
你本来压50块钱
那double的意思是我就是再压一个50块
但是只能发一张牌
那你有没有发现有些时间
他是告诉你像这个区域
如果你加起来的牌是9、10、11加起来
很值得double
然后像这些地方
他说你就都不要再发牌了
例如说你来到17基本上17已经很高了
再发也很容易爆
所以都不要再发牌了
所以他会去评估自己的牌的好坏
好
那我其实你不用背这个东西
网路上有各种针对basic strategy的影片跟教学
网路上好多
大家就自己看
你要问AI也好
我今天要聊的不是怎么打
Blackjack
而是他这个策略里面
他告诉我们做什么事
在赌桌上
你永远不知道下一副牌会发出来是什么东西
对吧
但是你可以知道的是
我这副牌跟庄家的牌
相对起来到底谁强谁弱
谁比较容易干嘛
而且如果你又再加上算牌
例如说小的牌都出来
你需要大牌或是庄家发大牌会爆
哦
你可以去算一下
对吧
来
这个网路上很多人有这个教学
这个大家自己去看
然后我有实际上真的完全照着这张牌打
然后在玩那个线上的那种21点
会赚钱
我没有跟你开玩笑会赚
就照着他
什么事都不用
就照着这个
因为你偶尔double的时候
那个运气真的很不错
偶尔你说你下double的单子
这样子
真的一定赚吗
有没有可能你下了double
结果这一局还是被吃掉
或是你好不容易拿的blackjack
21点结果庄家也开21你还是没赚到对吧 OK然后我要讲的是底下这两行
底下这两行
如果你拿到的牌偏弱或是持平
那我们就放弃发牌
我们就这样就好了
那如果我们拿到的牌偏强
就是刚刚讲的要double的
那就是要加码
所以它有些特定的地方是可以加码的
你可以用这张牌
然后这个basic strategy你去搜寻
各大网站中文版英文版写的都一模一样
都一样
所以他有一些规则就是他用四副六副八副牌
然后庄家在17以上就都要停了
这样子就是他需要有些规则
每个地方的小规则不一样
他就是适用这种规则的这样
OK
来
大家可以自己拿这个回去玩玩看
那我自己玩线上的
真的会硬
然后我叫我
我在教我儿子
结果他把他完成赌博
他有些时候就是不爽
就大单压
赚钱了好爽
然后下一笔大单压满
蹦一次就爆
这样
重点在底下这两个
这两个动作
对自己不利的机会
小赔测试
对自己有利的机会
加码测试
我用我自己的今天的这个小纳
这边不好做
虽然说有撑但是不好做
我用这个来当举例
你看一下那个距离
我在这边
我下几口
我看一下
我下
亏损的这边
最前面
最前面来这里
这里
所以我下两个
我下了两个
5 5 5这样子
所以总共10口单
总亏损是多少
总亏损是200
450吧
总亏损是450块
在这里
然后呢
后面你看一下
后面这里
这里
144这些
这些
这些部位
就是我最后出厂的这些部位
这招学起来
GTA6
我继续讲
所以我承受的
我用我的小风险去测试我先把这个show feel先拿掉好了来 大家看一下所以我在这边我下了两个5蹦蹦 我下了两个5
我这个测试是不是符合我平常做的事情
这是一个我熟悉的边界的2
而且这个地方
这个地方是7点45分即将8点钟
那这时候我就想要赌赌看
赌这个边界是有效的
有没有可能我在这一单就这样一路让我赌出去
或是赌出去回来有机会让我加码
有可能对吧
那有没有可能输
有啊
但是我输的时候
我并没有拉大我的风控
我仍然是这样子亏
所以总亏损就是450
那我后面这边
我仍然是承受一次450的风险
约略啦
反正我一样就是下5跟5这样子
那如果我这两趟
这边跟这边全部都打输了
那我应该就是回家
睡觉
睡个半天
睡到晚上
美股开盘再醒来
因为一个早上赔900
够了够了
因为我知道
当我早上如果亏
超过1000美金的这个刻度
我很容易陷入一个
不爽
我看着那个付的1000美金就很不爽
所以就想把它缩回三位数
最好缩回两位数
那这时候最好的办法就是下大单
本来是五五
接下来就是五五五五四个五
然后这一窥就付两千多
一笔单就直接没了
对不对
这样懂这个想法吗
所以我在做的这个地方
我是不是也在赌我的边界二
这是我熟悉的哦
熟悉的边界二哦
这样子
那你说我在赌的东西
看一下打开
好这样子5K应该看得很清楚
我现在按在这边
所以我就是抓这个区域
曾经有上去没有真的出去
然后这里就走掉了就没有了
所以一下子以后就大概4跟5分K以后就不见了
这样
那他的出场我不确定为什么会出在这里
因为他是自己停损的
我觉得他怪怪的
因为他是系统直接停掉的
有可能是触发在这边
然后最后一秒刚好
插下一根这样
我不懂
OK
满壘出局掉一分赶快离开
对大概是这种感觉
我没有在东兴路的棒球场打球
因为那边不是我们球队练球的地方
怪怪的咯
来我举个例子
如果现在我要做多
假设我要做多
我就会评估了
眼前的排面
对我是不是有利或不利
我会评估这件事
第一个评估
短线这么多压力
就代表我手上的牌是弱的
对手的牌可能是偏强
这时候再评估一下
大科度
大科度什么区
什么区
满足区
这里到这里的满足区
所以这边很容易震荡
也不是空头的满足区
对吧
那我就知道
这时候台面上对我有第一个不利是短刻度
第二个不利是大刻度的满足区
所以我就知道说这边我的部位不好做
那不好做我就干嘛
缩手
讲到21点
大家有一部电影应该都有看过
就是那个Blackjack
它的中文叫决胜21点
当然那个是电影
电影的剧情是否是真的我不知道
但是他里面他们做的动作
我觉得是一个很值得参考的
他们会派一大堆他们的伙伴
同伙进到赌场里面
那好几桌都在玩blackjack
他们会去算
算这一桌的牌
哪一桌的牌
剩下的大牌比较多
比较容易抽到大牌
他就去押注
所以他们派出去的前面这几个人
每个人都去下最低注
就是每一桌他有一个最低下注金额
他下最低注的目的就是他在测
测他的那个牌面
他会加1减1
大家自己去Google搜寻算牌这件事
总之他在测他的牌面
突然间某一桌的牌面
测出来数字越来越大越来越大
他就做一点手势挖个鼻孔
抓个下巴脖子
反正打个手势
然后大玩家就进来
一来就是1万美金1万美金的压
这样子
这个是不是也是在舍弃掉那个小的金钱在干嘛在测试这个市场
所以我们就只是在测试什么时候对我们有利
大家都在瞎子摸像哦
你是这样子我是这样子
连大基金大法人们他们也是这么做
只是他们比较有资本
他们有能力凹单
有能力甚至有能力摊平
人家是大基金的
例如说那个981
他不是在国际跌下来的时候狂买吗
对不对
那那些是基金法人的做法
我们其实是不一样的
我们没有那种等级的资金
对吧
我同学说交易的时间
对天时地利人和其实是哦
其实是哦
好不好
来
那你看哦
这种我们其实无法保证
眼前这副扑克牌一定是我要的
它打出来的单子一定是我要的
我也无法保证眼前的小那
例如说眼前这个小那
我说我不喜欢下单
结果待会狂喷给我看
直接打我的脸
我们都无法保证下一秒钟
市场会发出什么牌
但是我们能保证的是
我看到什么固定的迹象
做什么固定的事
来又回到前面这张
扑克牌会发出来的迹象
上面装家会拿到的牌
跟我手上拿到的牌
例如说我有一张A一张2
一张A一张5
这些动作是固定的
那既然两边都是固定
代表你就可以找到一个
固定要做的事情
你懂意思吗
那固定要做的事情
跟我们在做交易上面一模一样
你不能掺杂着个人情绪
他叫你不要抽牌就不要抽牌
他叫你抽牌就抽牌
你不可以因为
来重点哦
不能因为钱一把照着这个表
左我抽这个牌
结果输了
赔钱了
你就认定抽牌是不对的
因为他不是只看一笔交易
也不是只看两笔交易
他是看全部的交易
所谓全部是指可能是数字那个数量
大起来以后的总结果简单的说是統計數據這樣子莊家的確長期來說勝率比賢家多的那麼一些些
這倒是真的
因為要爆炸是賢家先爆
莊家是最後一個爆
因為都是先發賢家的牌
有人說DS是什麼意思
我也不知道
可能是Double或Stand都可以
這個我還要再去看它的說明
你可以Google一下
我记得我这张牌
这张图好像是我Google这个的图片
前几个图片而已
大家应该就可以找得到一模一样的东西
你可以去看一下他网站的说明
或是找中文版
或是你问AI应该都可以
好不好
我只是要讲的是
我们在市场上面
如果是固定的迹象
像我前面打的这个边界2
它是在大科度的下源
大克路的下源好
然后这边有平平的有边界
好吧
我用一个400多美金
我来试试看
OKOK
那试失败了
好吧就失败了
所以如果之后又有回来
假设又回来到这里
我下一个长线单
我在观察的边界是在29200跟29250这附近
我还不知道他会停在哪里
所以我最希望的是他杀一些下来
杀到这边开始长脚
哦
这样
那如果他有在这边长脚
我是不是就会评估说
上边界跟下边界
哦
那如果都已经来到下边界
这些是我方阵营
跟我站在同一边的军队容易出马
帮助我的单子的地方
那我就在这边等
等看他哪时候要出马
哦
那如果他有出马的
我就开始评估了
我手上的牌面
跟对方的牌面
如果对方是有这种
下杀杀很凶
往下杀的K棒
然后杀杀杀
再杀一个K棒变小根
再杀一个结果杀的过程中
K棒拉回来
变成了一个十字线的K棒在这里
我就可以往左边对过去
哎呦在这里
在这里出现十字
十字的意思是
是像这样子
下影线长的十字
是代表买方不知道是谁
他很用力而且这个用力有能力打破下跌的惯性然后把它买回来哦那这时候我就可以把这个边界
拿出来当做我的参考边界
哦好那这个框框可能可以开始准备做交易
那这时候我就是躲在那个有能力买回来的大户的后面
那我评估这些干嘛
在我的脑袋里面
这个时候就是在这张图里面的
值得double的地方
值得出手要牌的地方
值得把你的钱放进去的地方
就是这样子
那放了有没有可能会亏
一样啊跟扑克牌一样啊
你的牌很好20点就撞价开21
还是把你吃掉
对吧
就是有可能会亏
棒球也是如此
但是你就是照着一模一样的迹象
然后长期下来
如果你一天照着这样打
两天照着这样打
三天五天
一个月三个月
我通常能够打到三个月都乖乖的这样打的人
他的基本动作整个习惯
标准动作应该都练起来的
这样
所以如果你都已经练成那样
你就知道说什么情形
是是几率偏向我
几率哦
不是肯定哦
几率偏向我
啊什么情形几率偏向对方
那我就缩手
这跟
这跟那个什么
孙子兵法
我不是常常讲吗
孙子兵法他地形篇也有说啊
我们要坐在对方
走很远很累的地方
然后我们在干嘛
趁火打劫
对吧
等人家很累的时候
我们再把他打败这样就好了
所以我们一直在做这两件事情
强的
人家强我就不要进攻
等人家弱了我就踢他一脚
就是这种耍剑的事情
AI说照着表打
这的确是迷思
来
我说照着表打会赚钱
不代表長期一定賺錢
說不定我賺賺賺一下就賠掉
對吧
照著表打是其一
他還有另外一個叫算牌
只是現在賭場也很聰明
他們也知道你會算牌
所以他們會固定時間
直接把牌湊回去洗牌
这一洗牌你刚刚算到的那个加1-1加5-5那个都不用了
因为他重新洗牌了
重来
所以赌场也知道你在干嘛
这样
好不好
没错
AI说的没错哦
所以我们不做撞墙单是我们等别人撞墙
然后甚至我们眼前看到的是
你看哦
例如说这边就好了
我的部位會出在這裡來我用我的單子來舉例
這個時候是我們台灣時間的中午12點
這時候那我的習慣早上如果有部位
我抱到中午這邊
這裡又是大顆度的壓力區
是不是容易出現震盪或壓回來的地方
我本來的想法是我出掉以後他有機會回來開盤價
我再來吃,結果不回來,可惡
這樣
所以我也在評估眼前的部位的大小
然後我什麼時候丟這個部位進去
然後什麼時候收單
我在這邊收一個後面發現還是上我們去
好啦收一收,反正就是這樣子
收完以後後面這段時間我有看
但是就是可能一個小時後看一下噴出了
然後後面再看一下又噴了,好吧
没机会下就这样子
有同学说今天才敢在台子期10.55
5分K下多单
那我们来看一下台子期
台子期
所以如果照着以前自己乱下
还会投铁下空单
想顺势下跌
哦
这边对不对
这里这里
这个多单很漂亮
这里这里有这个下影线告诉我
这边这个边界
边界边界边界是有人用的
你下的单子好美
好美好美
那个点刚好也是小纳
同一个就是11点的那个点
同一个点好美
这个互换
它的暗示有够清楚
如果你回到当下
这个这个十字的暗示
它就在暗示你后面还是会
會一直走 很不錯啊
然後哪知道台子棋今天就從這裡這樣一路上來現在一樣包含台子期也是这边我看到的都对多头,怎么样
如果你把这张单子
反过来看,你看到什么
下跌,跌多长少,跌多长少,跌多长少
突然间变成,变成怎么样
应该跌下去,结果却跌不下去
反过来,变成长多跌少,长多跌少,长多
是不是跟这个图很像
所以他只是反过来而已
OK
有人说是不是一个人能某种程度观察自己的情绪跟自己
才能长期在试唱
是
尤其是情绪这件事情
我因为
我因为情绪的作祟
不止一次哦
然后让我丧失了好多好多钱
因为情绪上来
然后有好多钱是我情绪上来以后把钱被我赔掉
结果之后行情涨回来
我结果我前面的钱已经被我赔掉了
我又是空手看着行情狂喷
就很闷你知道吗
但是你初期我觉得大家需要经历好几次的这种情绪的灾难
你才会慢慢的借由这些很痛苦的情绪
然后观察到自己的弱点
然后学会一段时间后
学会跟自己的情绪去相处
这样
这很难
我到现在也还在学
但是就是很难
会建议放几倍保证金做一口
我的认为是如果是做期货
三到五倍是合理
你不要放太少
不要放一倍到两倍而已的保证金
例如说保证金要四千美金
你放个5000美金就跑去做
这个我觉得很
很硬
好不好
我们看他眼前开盘了
我刚刚是不是说
我刚刚是不是在这边讲说
来我刚刚有没有讲
我刚刚有没有讲说这个地方
说这也不利
现在不要乱做多
现在那个图很
很不好做
对多单来讲
有办法在情绪不好的时候
好好跟小朋友说话吗
讲到这个就是暑假的痛
所有有小孩的都知道有小男孩的都知道好啦没有啦我们家小孩很乖的啦只是偶尔会会有男孩的情绪以前的我其实会大发雷霆
现在的我还是会生气
但是现在我的生气
比较像是生气给他看的
这样子
而不是真的很生气这样
对啊
所以给这位下
下这个台子旗的一个掌声鼓励
其实你很会看的
很棒很棒
来
那我自己在
看的时候
有几个东西
像
我错过那个日线
其实我有点
因为我知道日线这里是
是大刻度的边界
我知道
然后在小10k里面
我会愿意在这边下单
但是我知道小10k这里很美
所以如果我11点多
在这边我有吃到这个部位
我绝对不会现在走
因为它终于出现日线等级的这样
所以我现在在等
我在等这件事情
这附近
这样
讲太多儿子的坏话
之后老的会被推轮
你推下来
对不对
而且老的他也不会帮我请
漂亮的看护
不能讲
我老婆说的
老了以后再说
NQ正在等他下来
我也在等他下来
那看来好像不下来
不要这样子
这边我不知道怎么做
真的是
来
我刚刚讲到现在
其实我都一直在做一件事情
叫做我在评估
例如说
说Amazon
我随便开
前一段时间在底下的这个点
这个地方如果你是当时看到的
这个点
你就可以评估一下
市场在这种关键边界
230这附近出现这种东西
它是不是在告诉你
我的对手就是做空的人
死的差不多了
哇这个下眼线好强
对吧
反过来说
当他涨到上面的时候
是不是对空方来讲
做多的人在这边来到这个地方
没力的怎么冲都冲不上去各种上瘾线在这個地方有沒有 那現在呢現在有點這裡有支撐 對 現在短期有壓力 所以我就等他回來這附近
有吃到的你就先抱著 大概就是用這種心態
有沒有 然後你說
小娜噴上去的 我也沒辦法 這個單子就是我會放掉
然后我就会说扑克牌发出了
哎呀早知道我应该要牌的
要到我就21点了
但是我就放掉了
我就乖乖的这样子照做
好不好
所以我一定会有照着我的机会放掉的单子
但也会有照着我的逻辑而躲掉的亏损
所以两边一来一往其实不会差太多
最麻烦的是你没有照着纪律
照着该有的基本动作来做的时候
却赚钱
这时候你会开始飘
因为你的心思全部跑到钱那边
我可以凹啊
我可以追啊
反正赚钱
例如说我刚刚追在29340
刚刚追的人现在到360赚20点
耶
对吧
你会认为这样子做是可以
当然有喷出当然好啊
但是麻烦就是麻烦在你的基本动作
会因为这样子而歪掉
你会觉得自己好像这个也可以
那个也可以
既然什么都可以
那你要求基本动作就没有意义了
然后我敢保证的是下一个阶段
你赚到这种不照规矩来的快钱
下一个阶段肯定是一直赔钱
一直赔钱
而且这一赔可能要赔半年
因为你又觉得这样好像可以赚钱
凹单好像可以
对啊
但是凹一次好痛
那到底要怎么办
会赚到啊
但是又很痛
不然我就换其他的
然后这半年你会用各种的逻辑
各种的东西都换来换去
而不是像人家这张表格一样
很明显对方拿什么牌
我拿什么牌
然后就做什么事情
这样子
我之所以拿这个表格来讲
不是跟你说照这个表格就必赚
这只是basic
基本的策略
但是打扑克牌是有这样子的逻辑
交易也是赌博
所以他也是有一个固定的逻辑在那里
好不好
黃金的小10k真的嗎 我看一下
現在9點35如果小10k要做有點硬 看一下30k
哇這個30k我看到底下是這樣漲上來
然後這邊是這樣子這樣子這樣子 然後這邊這樣子的
這個30k我不太想吃
那小10k的话
现在这个小时还有一半
现在才9点35
所以我应该
我不会想要在这里吃
因为我在这里吃
我的左下方
注意我的左边这边
没有下影线帮我撑腰
我那时候黄金之所以
会想要吃在这边
是因为有这个人
跟这个人帮我撑腰
我在赌他们有效
这样子
当然我手很短
如果我手远一点可能就过了
但是我不會因為這樣子而回頭去檢討
我就擺明就是要賭短短的
賠170剛好看到賠掉就算了
所以剛剛這張圖我不喜歡做的是做
這邊長到這裡
然後這裡又出現假突破概念
甚至壓力一直掉下來
一直掉下來
所以我剛剛才講老魚在說你有沒有在聽
这边这个单子
尤其是这个再继续破的几率
其实很高很高
我也没有办法完全掌控
我错过单子
我还是会不爽
甚至我也会把家里的忙碌的情绪
带到交易市场来
我也会
像我最近对自己最不爽
就是7月底那一段
其实是我很适合吃单的时候
但我偏偏选在那一周
跑去日本玩
然后我的习惯是当我出去玩的时候
我就会整个人好好玩
我就完全不太管
我除了长线的股票以外
我不会像人家去国外
还很认真做交易
我不会啦
我就是反正就是玩
而且我还要开车啊
还要干嘛的
所以其实事情很多嘛
那我就错过那个
七月那个很好吃的点
然后回来
第一个礼拜还生病
我不知道是什么生病
反正就第一个礼拜就还生病
所以生病的那段时间
又不能做交易所以眼前就这样子我也很闷啊那怎麼辦不能怎麼辦啊對啊原油比較美嗎
原油
原油我看一下
大顆度來到這裡
我看一下日線的樣子
日線來到大顆度呼喚邊界
我們看一下小10k
小10k现在出现这样子
如果刚刚这个原油的这一根
如果这一根它是这样子
它这里有戳的像这样子
戳到下面
看我这边
戳的比原来的低
打破边界又戳回来
然后在边界这里
假设现在是在这个地方
我会跟大家说
这个值得期待
这个下影线很棒
我边界都出来了
这边可以好好的等待
因为这就是刚刚扑克牌策略里面
对方露出破绽
他们已经没有大绝招了
大绝招都用完了
打出这个下影线
那如果有玩游戏的都知道
你就说骗对方把大招用掉
那个能量用掉
然后他又要再重新累积一次大招
骗他把大招用掉
然后换我们出大招
然后直接贴上去
对吧
有玩游戏的都是这样子
对不对
我这样讲应该大家很能够理解吧
所以眼前我不知道现在
所以要嘛他上去再回来
要嘛破再回来
他现在的位置就
就我不知道呢
所以我会有点犹豫
哦小那来看一下
这个30k跟60k
如果这个30k涨了一个这样长长的上影线
后面这几个小时往这边走的几率就很高
好不好
小10k也是啊
小10k现在两边在增
那假设待会20分钟后10点钟这个k棒
它是一个停在中间
长上影线也长下影线的k棒像这样子
像这样子我会觉得不好交易
那我就会去观察更短格局
注意十字线放大我会去看他是先上后下的十字线这是十字嘛 对不对还是先下后上这样子
这个我不敢说
所以我就要等到后面才说这样
所以现在这边我的评估
这个牌面就是普通不值得出手
普通普通普通不值得出手的这种牌面
那就等吧
那我们回来看黄金
来黄金刚刚打破对不对
打破回来
现在回来的对不对
来
现在9点41分
如果他这边回来了
回到这个地方
假设回到这个地方
54321这个小时可以停了
隔壁停在这边的话
我也会觉得不是那么友善
因为第一个K棒本身还是大根
第二大刻度的角度是在上面这种地方
所以这张单子你要下
假设你本来下五口
这张单子你要下你可能就缩
缩到剩两口三口
降一半以下的部位
然后如果这个三口
假设你用三口吃
吃对了又上去了
回来再把剩下的两口加回来
都比直接一次的五口好
这样
你有同学说先下后上跟先上后下
来我们来聊一下
回到刚刚的小那
如果这边是这样子
看我里面画
先下后上回来
其实这个后面上面回来的这个
它是不是由上往下来踩这个边界
那其实对多头是比较有利的
但是
但是它如果是很凶的呢
对吧
所以我知道它短线很凶
趋势是往下的
往下没错
所以我会在这边等
等什么
等它在更短一个刻度
停住的什么东西
下影线
假设我眼前看到的是
是十字线
是60K
那我要下的K棒
是5分K就会是5分K
先这样子又这样子
但是这样其实还是在这个中间
上边界跟下边界的中间如果像这样我不见得会下单反过来如果是先上后下的这里有能力起来但是起来这边也是撞墙单
我也没有办法
立刻就吃到多单
那我就要重新等
只是短线的力量是往上的
那我就重新等什么
等它征服
看是征服这边
还是征服这边
我不知道
倒琼,我們來看一下倒琼
YM
5分K哦
看5分K以前我會先看一下小10K
大邊界小10K很兇
但是是短線的可能15K或5分K的滿足區
这么凶的K棒其实后面
这是15分K的
在1分钟在56秒K棒就收
我跟大家讲
一个15分钟能够走这么远的距离
那代表后面于坡荡漾
继续往这边走的几率蛮高的
所以我会选择忍耐一下
等他在下一个15分钟
也就是说我真正能下单的时间点
应该会是有一个15分钟的空档
因为这个15分钟以后我需要隔壁的15分
可以走一走变成像这样子
再杀一下
然后隔壁的15分K拉回来
所以出现这样子K棒变小根
我比较可以观察云地停顿
那你想象一下嘛
如果下一根15分K走这样子
是不是短线里面的K棒
是不是这样子的机会
是不是比较像破底翻的样子
会在这个地方
那你说老爷这边
哇停住就直接上了
就给他上
这种我们就会退一步
我看起来继续破的机率其实蛮高的
包含短线也是啊
剛剛5K這邊在這裡就要撐住了
這些都撐不住
然後斜斜的下來這個往下破
很快很快就破了
來了來了
我鼻勒
來了
對吧
Intel是不是好東西
我看一下 intc 我記得我這裡有
我看一下周線
講intel的同學不錯耶
日線有下不去
那心中有個底
他這邊今天出現上影線對不對
所以代表這邊其實這一塊
這些人都還是有壓力
那如果是我可能多等个一两天
因为本周才是第一个这样子整理的周
对吧
今天是周二而已
我多的等个一两天
因为这个十字线
现在这个十字线的概念
跟我刚刚看到小纳十字线的想法
有点像
就觉得
他如果出现这样
其实他再回来测87.5这附近的几率
其实蛮不错的
这样
好不好
有人要秀我的对账单
来来来
我问你
如果我秀对账单
那你要干嘛
你要干嘛
你就会跟我买课程吗
我课程50万一堂课
要不要
对吧
我秀对账单
假设真的很赚钱
我真的赚钱
代表你也能赚钱吗
对不对
这个
然后
很好笑的是
你要问我秀对张
你知道我眼前开的这些是我自己的增仓
也不是什么TS或是Trackify的这种考试账号
都不是这些是我增仓
我开增仓一路这样做给大家看
已经做多少年了
大家应该自己知道
对吧
所以如果你花一点心思给这位同学
你花一点心思回去追
我觉得你应该不会花心思的
我建议你左转拜拜
好不好
你花一點心思回去追過去的直播其實都在這邊
對啊
好不好
送酸民進監獄
不會啦
他還沒有酸
他只是叫我修對帳單而已
但是講到這邊我要特別拉出來講一個事情
我順便一邊看一下
破掉了
破掉了 有没有林伯 你说我们在眼前看着这个即時盤對你們來講大概會晚個十幾二十秒但對我來講這就是即時盤
對不對
對啊
所以
我要講的是
我如何在即時盤裡面
然後看到一些跡象跟大家說我這樣不對這樣對
這樣我不想做這樣想做
這個才是我的know how能夠帶給大家的東西
所以其實剛剛這位同學
我覺得你的焦點放錯地方
你很容易被外面那種秀對帳單的詐騙給騙走
對帳單不簡單
你Google搜尋一下
有一個東西叫做對帳單產生器
股票的也有
然後各家券商的背景
全部都有
然後那個虛擬貨幣更不用講
你自己搜尋
你愛什麼愛多少對帳單
我就升多少對帳單給你
這有什麼用
對吧
但是我剛剛能講的是眼前的這些黑棒
為什麼我覺得這邊不能吃
然後行情真的下去了
就要把剛剛我說的那個不能吃的一些動態
記起來為什麼我說這邊上影線這邊怎麼樣
對不對
好不好
所以我覺得這個
這個才是我能給大家
而且這是即食的東西
這個也騙不了人
我如果跟大家講不要吃
但是涨上去的怎么办
不能怎么办
例如说刚刚的小娜
或是黄金
来来来
刚刚我是不是说黄金
我刚刚是不是一开始
我就说黄金这边
不喜欢不喜欢
有没有
这个地方
对呀
那我刚刚如何在
这个地方
我们怎么做出
当市场出现我要的那个规则
刚刚不是有那个21点的两条规则吗
他的牌出现怎么样的时候
跟我的牌出现怎么样的时候
是适合跟不适合交易
有没有
这个才是你能够带得回家的东西
而且所有的这些东西
我在这边直播这么久
我一毛都没有跟大家说
对吧
所以就这样
要教人要证明自己的实力
你就不用学就好了
拜
对不起我要疯了
封 你会看着我封锁你 怎么按不到试试 诶 等一下 哪里在哪里在这里诶 诶 为什么按不出来
我不要封错人诶
哦 有了有了
等一下我要确定我按对 按一下
哦 是这一个
诶 隐藏
好了 呆了
我不知道隐藏还看不看得到
坦白讲我不知道
因为我从来没有用自己来封锁自己
试过的
这样
OK
不过黄金这边我倒是看到不一样的东西
黄金我看到的是
这边该一路的这样子
这里应该要大K棒
像刚刚前面这两根一样
应该要一样大的K棒下去才对
但是该下去没下去
好
短线看来有点
不行 5k还是很丑
没有
小道勒
不行
来 我们刚刚是不是切
切
各位还记得我刚刚在15k我做的什么事吗
我刚是不是说
说这边
我说这边 这里
这样子
有没有
我说有出现这样子你再来做都不迟
现在
所以如果像剛剛你是急著想下單的人
你聽了這樣子沒有下單
哦!你就可以把我們剛剛這幾個動作學起來
第一個 K棒很兇
15分鐘有能力從53760
一路的走到53540
對吧?那短短的時間可以走這麼久
這就跟雲霄飛車一樣啊
他是垂直的這樣子下來的
我们怎么可以奢望它可以在下一秒钟就停住
不可能啊
它一定是下来
然后经过一种各种波浪
它才会缓解这个下沙的力道
这很简单的道理
好不好
所以我们说如果出现这个
这样OK吗
开始了
你看他开始在抵抗
那我们不用急
你是做15分K的人
你就不用急
你等你等他真的停住再说你就等那个15K如果这个15k有出现在这个边界大概在这附近这样子
现在是9点53还有6分钟
这个15分可以会收
我是觉得做15分K的你就等
你说老鱼但是现在拉回来了耶
那也有可能在这6分钟又下沙
对吗
那你就乖乖的等15k停住
我们今天讲的东西来来来
老鱼在说你不在听
我们刚刚是不是说鱼坡荡漾
我们刚刚是不是讲的一个这个在这里
你们伯爷你说有你听不
对吧
但是如果这个15分K没有停住
它仍然是下影线比较短
然后假设是这样
下影线只有到这里
然后上半部的实体可以放这么大
像这样子
下影線只有這樣
像這樣子的K棒 我不會下多單
就代表今天這兩根15k都沒有意圖要停下來
那我就再等 等等等
這邊正好是一個好案例
這個你看到行情要上漲以前 剛好又是它的開盤價
行情要上漲以前
看這一根
這一根
它是不是一個長下影線上半段比較小
的K棒
而前面都是大K棒大K棒下沙邊界長這種東西
後面長出去的機率就高了
哎要被我說中了你看
我再多的筆都不夠丟啊
來我們看一下NQ
NQ15K这样算上不去吗
的确上不去
只是他回来收的位置有点尴尬
就是他收在这个
假设这15分K收在这里
我隔壁一根15分K在这里做单会有点尴尬
因为下有撑上有压
如果他15分K是在这上面的边界
我反而比较好做
他收的太下来了那就那就算了
然后我跟你说刚刚出现这种上不去又回来的这里
下面这边这个多单不要乱接
310的多单拜托不要乱接
拜托 我为什么会这样讲
短时间可以这么凶这么凶的下来
现在9点55了
他摆明要让小时可以出现一个长上影线
这样
如果出现这种长上影线剩5分钟而已
后面这几个小时
我就知道我可以直接去睡觉
这样不好做
记忆相比过去
怎么捐笔
捐棒球好不好
棒球消耗得很快
就是在各大公园或是迪卡农的草丛里
都应该有我们一式的棒球
来看一下我同学问股票
我们看一下
3多少
周K按哪下班
我是按到什么
周K
周K是打击区的吗
其实周K很明显看得出来有大户在吃
而且这个大户他们是偷偷吃
他没有带量吃
对吧 偷偷吃 偷偷吃
那就代表大户可能也不希望价格涨太快
那你就跟着偷偷吃 慢慢吃 慢慢吃
可以从大格局的角度来看
的确是场下影线
但是有个隐忧就是
来到这边他都大户就不吃了
只要稍微高一点大户就不吃
大戶是压着下面48块多49块出头这附近吃
来到50块他们就不想吃
所以你心中就有个底
大户们大概在做的事情是这样子
好不好
2308 15分K 等一下等一下
不要看15分K吧
15K
是空方打擊區不行哦
不行哦來來來
我們要定義一個明確的東西是上邊界跟下边界打击区要定义出来我需要至少要有一个点两个点两点一线并且破隔壁
像刚刚我们看到的那个黄金下面回来的地方跟刚刚那个小道琼
他是在底下回来的那些地方
像这样子的概念才是我们要的
但并不是
来这个边界而已
它也没有破
它也没有长上隐线
不行哦
不行不行不行
好不好
而且你眼前看到的是
过去这这么多个15分钟力量往哪里走
我不知道明天会怎么样
但是眼前我看到的是这样子
这样
那我不觉得你需要用到15分K去做个股
各位拜托
如果你用15分K做个股
你会有点浪费
浪费长线个股的威力
好不好
真正个股的威力是放在日线周线的那种等级
哇你把它整个拉出去
威力很恐怖
你不用下大
但是一旦整个出去那威力就
很夸张
好不好
什么叫就夸张
所以
问2308空方15分K的这个
NQ下来了
我已经
我刚刚不是说这边不要摸吗
有没有
不要乱来
眼前这样看到
我第一个看到的直觉就是这个
來啦下來啦把這一段給帶下來快點快點
這樣子
可以講一下今天8點吃最低點跟初在11點進出法嗎
偷影片酷酷的東西有嗎?什麼東西?
什麼東西?這個嗎?來這個
應該是這個吧?對我的書準備出來了
我已经明确的交稿
我也把图片都编上那个图片
几知己的那个编号的这样子
然后没有想到将近10万字
对不起我太会拉勒了然后我又要求要全彩因为里面我有放好多图甚至有些是连续动作的图
就是第一张这样子
第二张这样子
第三张这样子
这样
所以连续动作的图
然后底下这里
他是跟我讲交稿时间
就是出书的时间
那我想说这个是编辑他们的事情
我就不想要给大家这样
好不好
你要给谁写序吗
给我老婆吗
我不觉得其他的作者
会很喜欢我来写我的序
因为我都
例如说人家会看基本面的
人家会看财报
会看筹码
我什么都不看
所以他们来写序
不就等于是直接打他们吗
我就这样不好了
穿插优雅图
穿插优雅的图
我的书就不用出
现在也不用
应该下个礼拜就没有直播了
各位
今天就是最后一次直播
我这辈子也来最后一次
请大家为我默哀
10万字我也不知道
还是到时候书商要分上下集
这个我也不知道
这个是我还要再跟书商讨论
所以接下来
找廖大跟Jack是ok啦
反正就是
接下来这两个月会是我密集要跟书商
他们说要我留时间给他们
会有各种来来回回
要跟我讨论各种东西
所以书的顺序基本上是这样子
就是前面我会讲交易的前置观念
一些心法最前面
中间有一大章节
都是我们的练习的菜单
就是我们过去在练的这个内容
从画两条线
从找标准图
这样一路下来到尖尖的等等
然后到教大家判断那个尖尖的概念
其实今天都有在讲了
然后
也有聊到股票
然后也有把后面我自己
产赔的记录什么的都放进去
然后最后面还有放心法
就是前面有技术
然后我们的心要怎么去hold住这些东西
这样子
电子版我来问苏商 我这边截图一下好了
截图一下 我截图 我来等一下我来丢给苏商 所以大家在问这些然后呢这是我刚刚一开始讲的台达电
我今天加在这里
我现在目前有四张台达电
所以目前就这样子
所以君教就约略在这附近
你看我说要破你看
而且我刚刚是不是
我刚刚是不是结了一个这样子的翻亚当
有没有
对吧
那现在它破了
对不对
其实这个破了
反而我觉得
是好事
只是这60k
哇
前一个60k长这样后面
不用理它了
我这个小时
根本就不用看盘了
好不好
希望它可以回来到这里
或是
如果有机会回来到这里
这里
长出尖尖的这样子
我又重新的
把我的常格局的单做出来
那现在各位
这个交易计划是不是
我最一开始就讲到的交易计划
那只是他来的样子很凶
所以我决定
你现在就要拿捏一下
你要用15k
用30k
还是用小时可以在这边等待
等着附近
OK
好了
那
讲到这个
那个有关于
像这些有新号是会员同学们
我应该预计会在
接下来这段时间
如果出书的过程中有空档
我看可不可以在台中再办一个像之前
那样子的聚会
就是会员同学的聚会这样
让我先等书商那边
跟我确认一下我需要
多忙的跟他这样子
如果OK我就办个聚会
这样
然后我可能还是会办到台中了
因为台中那个场地
我们之前好像预付
预付不知道多少钱
还没用完
所以场地费我出
大家就来就好了
所以都不用付钱就来就好了
这样OK
好了
那今天好像就这样子
其实就是一直在
在讲这些而已
这样
那最后我来聊一个东西
风险的金额
就是以下21点来讲
例如说旁边来一个大玩家
一次下单500美金
他最低注就500美金
那是因为他的背后
可能是有100单
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:20:00 起〕